Okay. Now I want to show you what happens when I
multiply L by U. This is the original Matrix. This
is the L Matrix now the upper Matrix. The U
Matrix is the
Matrix after we
eliminated everything below the lower triangle. So
that was this one.
I'm not going to scroll up because I have it right here.
array
So after we solve The Matrix a we
get one.
two negative 3
and then we have zero.
to
and then 0
and this would be seven.
okay, the idea is this If I multiply
these two matrices together I should get it back.
the original Matrix
Yeah, now we have the same Matrix.
Okay, so one two negative three one two negative 3.
and I can even neck convert this to and
Integer by using the as-type method, so I'm going
to go ask type make this an image integer.
There we go. So now we have the same Matrix as we had about.
You know one to negative 3 1 to negative 3 3 4 yeah.
But my point was this to summarize.
What we can do is we can take a square Matrix.
and
factorize it into two matrices.
the lower Matrix which is
The combination of the elimination matrices
we just saw.
And then once you eliminate eliminate eliminate you get to the upper
triangle Matrix.
So we need elimination of matrices
to get to the almatrix.
And once we get to the other Matrix, you would have also acquired the U Matrix.